un trágico episodio el luto a camerún en
la noche del lunes en el estadio o le
envié una estampida de personas que
intentaban entrar al encuentro entre
camerún y como ahora se terminó dejando
un saldo de al menos 8 muertos y 38
heridos siete de ellos de gravedad según
comunicó el gobierno camerunés en esa
misma declaración señalan que el
presidente paul biyá ordenó una
investigación para determinar cómo
ocurrieron los hechos según algunos
testigos la estampida ocurrió cuando se
abrió uno de los ingresos al estadio y
la enorme cantidad de personas que
esperaban fuera se abalanzaron sobre la
puerta provocando caídas de pisotones
que afectaron incluso algunos son niños
son los heridos fueron trasladados a
cuatro hospitales de yaundé aunque ese
traslado se demoró por el tráfico
intenso que había en la zona en esas
horas la confederación africana de
fútbol quedó obviamente en el ojo de la
tormenta como organizador de este torneo
ordenó también su propia investigación y
evaluará en una reunión de emergencia la
situación de seguridad es un hecho que
vuelve a poner en entredicho como está
llevándose a cabo una organización
bastante discutida del torneo se calcula
que unas 50.000 personas se acercaron al
estadio del mbe y alrededores en la
jornada de ayer en un estadio que tiene
capacidad para 60.000 y que tiene esa
capacidad reducida al 80 por ciento
debido a las medidas sanitarias aunque
ayer la cantidad de público que
finalmente terminó ingresando al espacio
al estadio pareció superar esa cantidad